take it to that hair bring you back is
that why they cut you from Norwich I
missed your Mane like you're not Rachel
from friends and yet
whatever you do to your hair it becomes
a thing yeah it does believe it or not
there's certain ones that I've just done
just off the cuff so there's no shame in
some of them before any weight for doing
it you had the top knot there you go
lovely burn that's always a practical
that's not bad yeah this one okay what
was going on here that was maybe a bad
decision yeah it was a bad time in his
world because I was actually going to
South Africa at the time with England
and I ended up meeting Nelson Mandela I
know you did and and the pictures the
maddest one the most um David Beckham
look I think is this one seemed like you
were tall big smiley face there no well
I don't know why I had that one I was
asked to shave it off when I first did
it I was I was sat in the changing room
and I had a hat on at the time because
Sir Alex Ferguson hadn't seen it so
obviously that was interesting when I
took my hat off and we had an hour
before the kickoff and he said go and
shave it off which I said no at first
and then I saw his face change very
quickly so I went shaved it off in the
in the toilet
Alex folks some would actually be some
strict on that stuff very really very
yeah what it is it was just you know it
was a reputation of the club wanted all
the players to kind of be professional
and he felt that it wasn't the right
look and I shaved it off we were playing
at Wembley as well so he kind of an
important and we just saw pictures of
you here in Paris with him at the match
and yeah smiling happy you obviously get
on now yeah we get on this but it did
get bad for a while um I mean it was
made worse than what it actually was you
know he was a father figure for me for
so many years you know he brought me to
the club that I loved as a kid I played
for the club I was successful at the
club with you know a number of the of
the young kids as well that we grew up
with so he gave me everything in my
career that I needed and so you know
he'll always be the man that I always
look up to because he gave me the dream
of playing for Man United
so who kind of held at the Olive ranch
who kind of went oh look it's well there
was no olive branch
it was just you know we just bumped into
each other at certain occasions after
I'd left Manchester United and you know
there was things that upset me and I'm
obviously I'm sure and well there
definitely was things that upset him
like I said you know I have so much
respect for him as a manager as a man
and you know like I said he gave me a
dream so you never talked it out you
just put it behind you yeah no we never
even discussed it where's Oprah that's
what I would never do you hear what he's
saying to you
he's Brooklyn he's now Brooklyn Romeo
and Cruz they're all at the Arsenal
Academy yeah and they take pictures with
all the fair and then I felt like this
wasn't you know yeah it's not
appropriate right no I